[موسيقى]
الجائزه في راي انها ستخبز صدى كبيرا
مترجم
الاصلي
والمترجم احيانا لا يرى في هذا ولذلك لما
هناك جائزه مثل هذا فهذا طبعا سيرفع
معنويه مترجمين
[موسيقى]
تكريم نفتخر فيه لكن انا صعيد المهني
بعتبره لا يقل اهميه لانه مهنه الترجمه
الى حد ما مظلومه
وباعتقد انه هذا التكريم يعني بنهض مهنه
ترجمه ككل
يعني خطوه كبيره في مسيره مترجم
المستويات التنفسيه الكبيره جدا زي ما
حضرتك شفت المراكز اكثر من المراكز
المتشارك بسبب قوه الاعمال للمشاركه في
الفوز في هذه المسابقات يعني كبير جدا اي
مشاركه همم
انا ما فكرت ابدا
بالحصول على جائزه
كنت دائما بارد همم
وترجم انا ترجمتر كثير من الكتب
همم العربيه همم اسلاميه من الدين فلسفه
حصول على هذه الجائزه همم يشرفني يشرفني
كثيرا
[موسيقى]